[Musica]
c'è qualcosa dentro la scatola hai visto
berlino
una sfera vitale viene a vedere cosa ho
trovato dentro questa scatola ho trovato
il trono scatola uno spera una bolla tu
non lo sai che quella scatola e
pericolosa rimetti tutto dentro non
toccarlo mi più sfera cosa vedi è falsa
c'è pure scritto lì non apriva e
chiudeva bene
ecco fatto l'ho chiusa non la tocca ero
più che io adesso vado perché il suo
mesi brucia però non toccarlo casa dopo
lo so che vitale ha detto di non toccare
la scatola ma io sono troppo curioso che
cosa sarà questa sfera prendiamole
portiamolo in camera senza farsi
scoprire la vita
guarda berlino che cosa secondo te a me
sembra una semplice sfera di cristallo
guarda marino li vedi anche tu per gli
effetti forse una sfera magica
wow sono bellissimi
cosa
pensi che stia cercando di comunicare
con noi
marino vuoi dirmi qualcosa dice che devo
stare attenta
beh forse hai ragione ma mi incuriosisce
troppo così misteriosa che c'è berlino
non ti piace questa sfera
ti sto preoccupando sta antipatica
questa sfera non mi dire che la vuoi
mangiare come frequenta si rumore
sentito un rumore strano che cosa stai
facendo niente
una challenge qui c'è qualcosa di
sospetto miseria
niente di sospetto non c'è niente di
strano va bene comunque pro pochi minuti
è pronto io di consiglio di arrivare per
tempo altrimenti io mi spacco tutto ciao
[Musica]
vuoi diventare una di noi che significa
forse una di quelle sfere che le scudi
ti danno una risposta
proviamo a è tornata trasparente solo
giocattolo andiamocene
[Musica]
non sono un giocattolo c'è qualcosa di
strano con questa sfera non pensate
anche voi sembra che voglia comunicare
secondo voi dovrei fidarmi onu che
strano sembrato di sentire un rumore
forse c'era anche una luce mi sembra
completamente vuota che mal di schiena
[Musica]
che cos'è quest
in un'altra niente stavo solo giocando
con berlino italiano dove scoprire che
ho preso la sfera berlino aiutami tu
l'italia non deve spettare ai ai rino
queste sono le mie ali non puoi
mangiarle mi fai male deve esserci un
modo di toglierle spera e vera di
cristallo fammi tornare come prima
giuro che non mi ero mai più che sei
solo un giocattolo peggio per te anita
ormai accettato la sfida ora dovrà il
superamento dei propri amici non vorrei
vivere con te perché non si illuminò più
non appaiono più le scritte non si sente
niente non succede niente
e va bene c'è bisogno di una misura
drastica
vediamo se funziona
[Musica]
e impossibile toglierle devo trovare il
modo di comunicare componente con la
sfera state frontier è una formula
sì sì tutto bene come dire questo sono
giocando con berlino idea frontre
vissuto questa coperta
niente ti ho detto sto giocando con
berlino stiamo costruendo una cosa e
perché una sorpresa sorpresa
[Musica]
dov'è la sorpresa
devo ancora prepararne ma se questa cosa
in genere avevo freddo quindi ho deciso
di mettere una coperta per ricevuto
freddo ci mostrano questa impalcatura
riesce qui è la sorpresa la sorpresa ceo
le sorprese e ancora non è pronta lo
scoprirai più tardi o che bello che
bello che bello non vedo l'ora donna
sospesa allora c'è mancato poco che
scoprisse l'eolico e vitale scopre che
ho preso la sfera è che ho causato
questo strano maledizione si arrabbierà
tantissimo perché lui aveva detto
dall'inizio di non toccare la sfera lo
avrei dovuto ascoltare che cosa vuoi da
me che cosa devo fare
se proprio devo vivere con queste ali
almeno
mi piacerebbe sapere se posso volare
sarebbe un sogno poter volare un'idea
senza farsi scoprire da vita ne usciamo
fuori
vediamo se riusciamo a volare con queste
ali almeno una cosa divertente di questa
maledizione a mi raccomando se non avete
ancora lasciato mi piace lasciate un bp
oggi il cli mi vorresti just a perdonare
per l'impegno io c'è un sacco di vento
non so se riuscirò a usare queste ali
con questo vento decisamente non riesco
a volare
purtroppo è tutto aumentando meglio
tornare dentro casa andiamo o no ragazzi
ora che faccio non riesco a toglierle
non riesco neanche a volare che poteva
essere la cosa più divertente di avere
delle ali aveva ragione di tale non
dovevo prenderlo non dovevo toccarla ma
non si attiva più vedete forse devo
usare qualche sorta di parola magica
magari è usato una parola che l'ha
attivata
hocus pocus
e speriamo che cosa stai facendo
ma cosa sono quelle è un costume di
carnevale il costume di carnevale in
anticipo per l'anno prossimo con la
sfera della sfera della scatola e va
bene sì l'ho presa ok è troppo curiosa
ero curiosa di vedere che cosa fosse
questo sfere qui non passano avuto io ho
detto solo uno stupido giocato e allora
diversi arrabbiata che invece di spero
anche da non so come fare arrabbiare la
sfera comunque ha deciso di trasformarmi
in una fata o un insetto a tempesta
sembrano alida fatto o alida insetto da
libellula è un incrocio tra ali da
farfalla realizzata proprio che non
riesco a volare ma ti riempi molto e
avevo detto di non toccare questa sfera
non hai ragione ma ora come faccio
ho provato a toglierle in ogni modo
allora innanzitutto non toccare più
quella sfera è la shaboo non posso
vivere con queste ali non ti preoccupare
insieme troveremo una soluzione
ieri a boe potrebbe evitare ben
preparati per la prima prova mia chiare
a partire
[Musica]